[Music]
no let up even after more than 70 days
passions are high and the numbers keep
growing at the farmers protest on the
borders of the national capital
they have left their fields and camped
in the dead of winter
calling for the repeal of the three laws
enacted by the indian government
the laws they claim will deregulate crop
pricing
reduce incomes and leave them vulnerable
to private companies
prime minister modi insists his
government has always had the interest
of the farmers
and is willing to suspend the laws for
18 months
last week passions ran high and the
months of peaceful protest
descended into violence as the farmers
marched into delhi
security has now been increased the
internet suspended at times
and social media blocked the farmers
remained
[Music]
unrelenting
[Music]
right wing activists protested against
singer rihanna
and environmentalist greta fundberg for
lending their support to the farmers
their tweets to millions of their
followers has
amplified the cause worldwide
we travel to the punjab to get a sense
of what fires
these emotions at the village of kandala
the laws and the ongoing protest is all
that is talked about
the farmers unconvinced by the prime
minister
are unrelenting
year old gurmeet singh his family is yet
to reconcile the loss
he had organized and led his people to
the protest in delhi
in the biting cold and living in a
tractor trolley for days
he died of a heart attack
[Laughter]
barwinder and his father have had this
land for generations
they believe the laws are a threat
our future children's life people of my
age
will quit farming if this happened
they will shift to businesses or jobs
which is
already unemployment rate is very high
in india
an overwhelming majority in the punjab
are farmers
almost every home in these villages have
sent
men and russians to the protest
a relay of keeping the supply lines open
and the pressure on
neville lazarus sky news kandala village
in punjab